basic income is going to be the bribe to
accept the microchip implant I fear
that's ridiculous
[Music]
will we one day be able to make accurate
economic predictions
or is economic Precision just a fantasy
Richard
it's not a fantasy um I mean if you look
at my forecast they've been pretty
accurate for the last 35 years last time
I sat together with Jillian Ted in Tokyo
in 1997. I think you know if she
remembers what I said I think it panned
out pretty pretty neatly that Japan
won't recover until Bank credit creation
recovers which was only 2013-14
um and the problem is in the banking
system and so on I propose the new
monetary policy 95 which are called
quantitative easing which is a quick way
of getting out but they refuse to adopt
it and then distorted it to prolong the
recession I had this false QE
um so so really it's possible yes it's
the answer but of course the powers that
be may not want it because they have
different agendas and that's what we
always have to keep in mind you know
what is the actual goal here guy do you
agree with that is it ever possible
no I I don't and I'm I'm drawing these
comments on a book by Nassim Talib uh
called the black swans two books and a
book anti-fragility
and basically his thesis which with
which I agree is that we have to learn
to live with uncertainty
we are not faced with an industrial
society situation where you can predict
the risks and then develop Insurance
systems so that gives people that we're
in the situations of globalization and
era of pandemics global warming where
shocks can hit all of us at any stage
we're all vulnerable okay and if in
those circumstances you recognize that
obvious but I I find it in a fairly
obvious fact if you like then you have
to develop systems that deal with
people's fragility to give them a sense
of resilience both at an individual
level and at Society level and at
economic level it's one of the reasons
why I support a basic income because
then you get people saying yeah I'm
going to be able to handle a shock
because if it hits me unless it's
totally catastrophic but at least the
within a range so I think we've got to
learn to live with uncertainty
let me just bring Richard back to to uh
to comment on that because completely
diametrically opposed here yeah so
Richard you want to come back quickly
well on two levels so I do think it's
possible because it you know they just
haven't tried and if you work
empirically it's not so hard you know
quantity of credit creation
disaggregated into uh Bank credit for
the real economy for GDP will tell you
what GDP is going to do and then for
asset transactions we'll tell you what
asset markets are going to do so it's
possible
um and then also the conclusion is
interesting you come to conclusion we
need a basic income and of course I
sympathize with this idea
um it was an old idea Century old but
why has it been favored since well the
last I don't know 10 years by all the
billionaires the Davos billionaire class
why are they favoring it because they
want to roll out centralization digital
ID and digital money and cbdc's and we
if you link that
um it becomes a very totalitarian system
so you have to ensure that we don't have
so much centralization okay and the
basic income is going to be the bribe to
accept the microchip implant I fear I
think that excuse me that's ridiculous
uh because one of the things that when
people have resilience they become
stronger about demanding other things
okay we need people to feel less fearful
that's the economic issue of our time
and less vulnerable so I think I think
the reality is there's a famous term uh
invented by a disgusting man Rumsfeld
unknown unknowns and we are facing a
future of unknown unknown we've already
had six pandemics this century
and we don't know when the next one's
going to hit we don't know when the next
there have been 500 financial shocks
since the beginning of the 1980s we
don't know when the next one will come
and I've defy all the neoliberal
economists have failed I think we need
to think out of the box for transforming
and and then the last comment I would
like to make if I may which is that one
of the the sins of this hegemonic system
is comes from what the What's called the
Austrian School of Economics which which
formed the background of the montpelerin
society and thatcherism and so on and
one of their tenets was the following
says anything that doesn't have a price
has no value
now that meant that automatically if you
privatize something that increases
economic growth and it's infantile for
politicians to be saying growth growth
growth
for me as a student we would have
thought this was mad
distribution matters distribution
matters
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit iai.tv for
more debates and talks from the world's
leading thinkers on today's biggest
ideas